بعد شد وجذب زلينسكي يعترف نعم
لقد خسرنا المدينة. والمستشار
الالماني يحضر رسالة قوية لروسيا
فما الذي تحمله الرسالة? والاري
كلينتون تعلن عن هدية امريكية
لبوتين وموسكو لواشنطن نهجكم
محفوف بالمخاطر وهذا اخر تحذير.
ومجلس الدوما يبدأ رده القاسي
على بولندا. وطباخ بوتين يعود
بسهامه مجددا نحو الخونة في
بلاده ومجموعة سبعة تتخذ قرارا
عسكريا ضد الصين فكيف سترد بكين?
الاحتلال ينتهك حرمة المسجد
الاقصى والمقاومة ترد بقوة وبين
ايران وباكستان حرب الحدود
تندلع. الانتحار الاوروبي. انقشع
الغبار لينجلي الضباب في
اوكرانيا ولتجوب اخبار الخسارة
الشرق ليعلنها الرئيس الاوكراني
فلوديمير زينينسكي صريحة باخموت
باقية في قلوبنا. نعم زيلينسكي
اعترف بان القوات المسلحة
الاوكرانية خسرت مدينة باخموت في
دمباسا وذلك على هامش قمة مجموعة
سبع في هيروشيما حيث كان زينسكي
قد رد على سؤال عما اذا كانت
باخموت لا تزال تحت سيطرة الجيش
الاوكراني ليعترف زينيسكي
بفقدانها حسب رويترز. لكن
زلينسكي وبرغم اعترافه قد زعم
بان الجنود الاوكران لا يزالون
في باخموت ليرد قائد فاغنر قائلا
بانه لا يوجد ولا حتى عسكري
اوكراني واحد في المركز السكني
بباخموت. مضيفا زلينسكي اما يكذب
او انه لا يعرف ما يحدث على
الارض لكن على الجانب الاخر وفي
ضواحي باخموت لا تزال القوات
الاوكرانية لم تطوي باخموت بعد.
حيث ان التصريحات الصادرة عن
قياداتها تتقاطع مع حديث الرئيس
حول المدينة. فقيادات الجيش
الاوكراني يقولون بان القتال لا
يزال مستمرا وضاريا في باخموت.
خصوصا وان قوات كييف تحاول تطويق
المدينة من الجنوب والغرب لترد
الدين للقوات الروسية التي حاصرت
الاوكران في ازوفستال. فهل ينجح
الاوكران بخطتهم هذه? ام ان رأيا
اخر. ليجيب المتحدث باسم قيادة
العمليات الشرقية الثانية سيرجي
شريفاتي ان الدفاع في الجزء الذي
تسيطر عليه القوات الاوكرانية في
باخموت اصبح اشكاليا. وان
الانسحاب من المدينة سيتم عاجلا
ام اجلا. وكان الشريفاتي قد نفى
ان تكون قوات فاجنر قد سيطرت على
باخموت. وقال ان القوات
الاوكرانية تصد هجمات في جنوب
غربي المدينة. فكيف غيرت حديث من
فوز الى خسارة بين ليلة وضحاها
يا هذا. ومع الاعترافات
الاوكرانية جاء الدور على طباخ
بوتين. ليدلي باعترافه ايضا.
نعم. هنا قائد مجموعة فاغنري
بريجوجن يقول ان عدد قواته كان
يجب ان يبلغ ثلاثة وعشرين ضعفا
لحجمها الحالي وفقا لمنهجية
الحسابات العملياتية والتكتيكية
التي اقرتها هيئة الاركان
الروسية. وارجع بريجوجن الى ما
سماه الخيانة. فعن اي خيانة
يتحدث? وفي سياق اخر اعلنت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية عن تحييد عشر
مجموعات تخريب واستطلاع اوكرانية
على مختلف محاور القتال واعتراض
خمسة عشر من صواريخ انظمة خلال
يوم واحد. ومن حرب المدافع
والبارود الى معارك الغرب مع
الروس. لكن عن بعد حيث قال
الالماني في حديث نقلته صحيفة
برلين سايتونج ان تدريب طيارين
اوكران على قيادة واستخدام
مقاتلات من طراز اف ستة عشر
سيكون رسالة لروسيا. ليرد نائب
وزير الخارجية الروسية الكسندر
جروشكو بان موسكو ستأخذ بعين
الاعتبار ضمن خططها نية الغرب
تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف ستة
عشر. واتهم جروشكو الدول الغربية
بمواصلة السير على نهج تصعيد في
اوكرانيا. مؤكدا انه نهج محفوف
بمخاطر هائلة على تلك الدول
نفسها فيما قالت الخارجية
الروسية ان الولايات المتحدة تشن
حربا هجينة ضد روسيا والمنطقة
باكملها. واضافت ان واشنطن تضلل
وتنافق بقولها انها ستمنح
اوكرانيا طائرات اف ستة عشر شرط
عدم استخدامها لضرب روسيا. وبعد
كل هذا المخاض العسير الذي تخوضه
الولايات واوكرانيا لمواجهة الدب
الروسي اعتبرت هيلاري كلينتون
وزيرة الخارجية الامريكية
السابقة والمرشحة في الانتخابات
الرئاسية عام الفين وستة عشر ان
فوز دونالد ترامب في انتخابات
الفين واربعة وعشرين سيكون نهاية
لاوكرانيا والديموقراطية في
امريكا ايضا بحسب ومن اوكرانيا
الى بولندا. بدأ خصوم روسيا
بالتكاثر ومع تصاعد التوتر بين
موسكو قال رئيس مجلس الدوما
الروسي ان المجلس ينظر في موضوع
اتخاذ اجراءات ضد بولندا بما في
ذلك عبور الشاحنات عبر اراضي
روسيا واشار الى ان بولندا
ستتحمل في هذه الحالة خسائر قد
تصل الى ثمانية مليارات ونصف
المليار يورو وفق ما اوردته
وسائل اعلام روسية. الاحداث
والتطورات. بعد القمة الاخيرة ها
هي دول السبع اتفقت على اتخاذ رد
عسكري موحد ضد الصين حال اتخاذها
اي عمل عسكري ضد تايوان دفاعا عن
الاخيرة وكان قادة السبع قد
اقروا في قمتهم المنعقدة في
اليابان عقوبات جديدة على روسيا
على خلفية حربها على اوكرانيا.
وشملت العقوبات قيودا على صادرات
سلع مثل الالماس. وحرمان موسكو
من التكنولوجيات والمعدات
الصناعية. بما تعهد القادة في
مسودة البيان ختامي للقمة بتقليص
الاعتماد على التجارة مع الصين.
الخارجية الاردنية تحذر من تصعيد
خطير وذلك ردا على اقتحام بن
غفير للاقصى لان ذلك يمثل خرقا
للقانون وللوضع التاريخي للقدس
وفق الوزارة الاردنية. من جهة
اخرى وفي خطوة مفاجئة اجتمع رئيس
وزراء الكيان بنيامين نتنياهو
بحكومته في نفق تحت المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وذلك بعد ساعات
قليل من اقتحام بنخفير باحة
المسجد الشريف. ما اثار ادانات
واسعة فلسطينية وعربية واسلامية.
فيما نفذت المقاومة عملية دهس
على جنود الاحتلال في بلدة حوارة
جنوب نابلس. ارتفع عدد المشردين
في مدينة سان فرانسيسكو وهي احدى
اغلى المدن في امريكا بسبب
ارتفاع اسعار السكن. ووفقا
للبيانات الرسمية للعام الماضي
يعيش حوالي مليونان وخمسمائة
وثمانون الف شخص في الشوارع في
الولايات المتحدة وتتصدر ولاية
كاليفورنيا القائمة باكبر عدد من
المشردين منذ اكثر من عقد. ذكر
موقع ميزان اونلاين التابع
للسلطة القضائية الايرانية ان
ستة من حرس الحدود قتلوا خلال
هجوم في سروان في محافظة سيستان
بلوشستان الحدودية مع باكستان.
وفي سياق اخر كشف وزير
الاستخبارات الايراني انه تم
اعتقال مجموعة ارهابية مرتبطة
على الحدود الغربية للبلاد.
والموكييف مقاتلات اف ستة عشر
الامريكية يكبر يوما بعد يوم.
برأيكم هل ستستطيع هذه المقاتلات
اذا ما وصلت لاوكرانيا حسم
المعارك ضد القوات الروسية?